[Música]
se reunió en Brasil con el presidente
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva y volvió a
responsabilizar a occidente por la
invasión rusa Ucrania esto en medio de
la atención entre Brasil y Washington
que hoy acusó al mandatario brasileño de
repetir como un loro la propaganda de
Rusia y China sobre la guerra
el presidente Gustavo Petro aseguró que
dialogará con su homólogo estadounidense
Joe biden sobre un posible levantamiento
de sanciones a Venezuela el mandatario
colombiano será anfitrión la próxima
semana de una Cumbre internacional sobre
Venezuela que busca reactivar los
diálogos entre el gobierno y la
oposición Tenemos reporte
en una controversial decisión el
gobierno de chile aprobó el proyecto
minero los bronces integrado que
estipula ampliar un yacimiento en la
Cordillera de los Andes organizaciones
ambientales alertan sobre el impacto de
la iniciativa en la biodiversidad y en
la seguridad hídrica porque afecta una
zona con glaciares ampliamos desde
Santiago
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos damos inicio en
Brasil y a donde el presidente Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva se reunió con el
canciller ruso sergei labrov el
funcionario volvió a responsabilizar a
Estados Unidos y a la otan por lo que el
kremlin califica de operación militar
especial en Ucrania el encuentro se
produce el mismo día en que el portavoz
de seguridad Nacional de la Casa Blanca
John Kirby arremetido contra el
mandatario brasileño asegurando que
repite como un loro la propaganda de
Rusia y China sobre la guerra en Ucrania
estos días después de que Lula visitara
China y emiratos árabes Unidos donde
afirmó que Washington debería dejar de
incentivar la guerra y comenzar a hablar
de paz desde Brasil y a rechazaron los
señalamientos estadounidenses
No para nada no estoy para nada de
acuerdo no sé cómo llegaron a esa
conclusión en absoluto quién lo dijo
quién fue Quién fue
Bueno eso es todo No lo sé no sé las
razones por las que dijo eso en otras
noticias el fiscal Federal de Brooklyn
anunció la detención de dos ciudadanos
de origen chino acusados de facilitar la
operación del Ministerio de seguridad
pública del país asiático para montar
una estación policial ilegal y
amedrentar a compatriotas opositores al
gobierno de chilling en la misma jornada
del FBI hizo oficial las denuncias
contra una treintena de chinos por
formar una granja de trolls en redes
sociales que acosaban a ciudadanos
radicados en Estados Unidos que
criticaban la gestión en China Ramiro
cuevar berena tiene los detalles
parece un edificio común y corriente en
el corazón del barrio chino de bajo
Manhattan Pero dentro de él operaba una
estación de policía china no declarada
según denunciaron las autoridades
estadounidenses al fiscal de Brooklyn
comentó que en uno de los pisos se
brindaban servicios gubernamentales sin
autorización de Estados Unidos la
acusación más severa indica que este
edificio era utilizado por el Ministerio
de Seguridad Pública para operar contra
compatriotas críticos del gobierno de
chimpín un hecho por el que fueron
detenidos dos ciudadanos de origen chino
las denuncias acusan a estos oficiales
del Ministerio de seguridad pública de
participar en esquemas de represión
transnacional dirigidos a miembros de la
comunidad de la diáspora china en la
ciudad de Nueva York y en otras partes
del país
los acusados fueron identificados como
luciane One y cheng Quienes fueron
arrestados bajo los cargos de
Conspiración y obstrucción a la justicia
por eliminar presuntos contactos
telefónicos con el Ministerio de
seguridad público chino
Además este lunes el FBI oficializó las
denuncias contra una treintena de
funcionarios chinos por montar una
granja de trolls en redes sociales para
agredir a opositores y críticos del
gobierno de xin el director del FBI
repudió el accionar de los acusados
todas estas personas son agentes que
apoyan la campaña del gobierno chino
para exportar la represión y socavar el
estado de derecho en todo el mundo
incluso aquí mismo en Estados Unidos
dentro de los apuntados se encuentran
ocho personas que están prófugas y que
están involucradas en una causa de 2020
sobre intervención de reuniones de video
remotas que conmemoraban la masacre
tienen mente 1989 la fiscalía del
Condado de Klein en el estado
estadounidense de Missouri presentó
cargos contra un hombre que habría
disparado contra un adolescente afro que
se equivocó de domicilio se trata de
Andrew Lester de 84 años que fue acusado
de asalto en primer grado y acción
criminal Armada Ralph y el joven afro de
16 años iba a recoger a sus hermanos
Pero se equivocó de dirección tras
Llamar a la puerta Lester le disparó en
la cabeza y en el brazo El joven se
recupera de las lesiones
se trata de un delito grave conserva una
serie de penas de hasta cadena perpetua
en el segundo cargo Esta persona es
acusada de una acción penal Armada se
trata de un delito no clasificado y
conlleva una serie de penas de entre 3 y
15 años
desde la sede de la ONU en Nueva York
que el presidente de Colombia Gustavo
Petro afirmó que dialogará con el
presidente estadounidense Joe biden
sobre un posible levantamiento de las
sanciones a Venezuela el mandatario
aseguró que ese será el foco de la
Cumbre internacional sobre Venezuela
convocada por Bogotá para la próxima
semana la que participarán
representantes de Estados Unidos Europa
y varios países de América Latina que
han impuesto sanciones al gobierno de
Nicolás maduro Daniela Zambrano
corresponsal de France 24 en Caracas nos
amplió sobre la viabilidad de que
Estados Unidos levante las sanciones
impuestas contra Venezuela para poner en
contexto la audiencia es importante
recordar que el pasado primero de marzo
la propia administración
estadounidense prorrogó el decreto
tiene a Venezuela o califica Venezuela
como una amenaza para la seguridad
estadounidense y su política exterior
precisamente del decreto que permite
aplicar sanciones a países en
determinadas circunstancias y
recientemente también un portavoz de la
Casa Blanca advirtió que Estados Unidos
se reservaba el derecho de endurecer las
sanciones En caso de que hubiese más
represión contra los opositores que haya
incumplimiento de los acuerdos por parte
de Nicolás maduro por lo que no parece
tan viable que se puedan levantar las
sanciones en su totalidad tal y como lo
ha solicitado en múltiples oportunidades
Nicolás maduro y su gobierno una de las
primeras reacciones que ha habido a
través de las redes sociales a esta
propuesta del presidente colombiano
Gustavo Petro ha sido por parte del
dirigente opositor Juan guaidó quien
decía que eliminar las sanciones
extinguía la posibilidad de llegar a un
acuerdo y le da un cheque en blanco al
gobierno de Nicolás maduro para seguir
violando derechos humanos decía para que
hubiese cero sanciones Venezuela tenía
que haber 100% democracia y el hecho de
que no había democracia era las razones
por las cuales había sanciones sin
embargo También es importante destacar
que Estados Unidos decidió flexibilizar
las sanciones impuestas a la estatal
petrolera para que Chevron pudiera
explotar petróleo en Venezuela porque
tenía intereses económicos al respecto
en chile hay una fuerte polémica luego
de que el comité de ministros del
gobierno de Gabriel borich aprobara el
proyecto minero conocido como los
bronces integrado se trata de una
iniciativa de la minera anglo American
Sur que busca ampliar a su yacimiento en
la Cordillera de los Andes la
controversia se centra en que la mina se
encuentra en una zona con glaciares y
según organizaciones tendrá un fuerte
impacto sobre la biodiversidad y la
seguridad hídrica desde Santiago
Patricia Luna corresponsal de France 24
nos dio más detalles
por unanimidad el consejo de ministros
del gobierno de Gabriel boric dio luz
verde a la ampliación del proyecto
minero los bronces integrados que
pertenece a la minera global
angloamericana que supondría una
inversión de 3000 millones de dólares
para mantener y ampliar la vida útil de
este proyecto hasta el 2000-36 y
mantener así su producción de cobre lo
hace sujeto a una serie de condiciones
Como por ejemplo que angloamérica se
encargue de compensar el 150% de las
emisiones de este proyecto reemplazando
por ejemplo hasta 70.000 calefactores de
leña en la región metropolitana por
otros que sean menos contaminantes
mientras que para los ejecutivos de
anglo American esto abre la puerta a una
minería mucho más sustentable que deje
una menor huella ecológica esto ha sido
valorado muy negativamente por decenas
de personas y varias agrupaciones
mediante ambientales ambientalistas que
critican el proyecto como nefasto dicen
que no se condice con un gobierno
ecologista y feminista y afirma que
afectarán a las cuencas hídricas de la
región metropolitana y Valparaíso donde
se sitúa el proyecto y que son dos de
las más afectadas por la crisis hídrica
que se vive el país también temen por
los glaciares Aunque el proyecto
contempla un sistema de alerta temprana
de estos y también evaluación y
monitoreo de los valores de este gran
activo medioambiental
un equipo de científicos británicos
estadounidenses y Ecuatorianos
descubrieron un milenario arrecife de
coral en las profundidades de la reserva
Marina de las Islas Galápagos una zona
que según los expertos puede ayudar a
comprender mejor la crisis climática
moderna esta localizado a entre 400 y
600 metros de profundidad En la cima de
un monte submarino no cartografiado y se
extiende por varios kilómetros en el
centro del archipiélago
es todo por el momento en France 24
ustedes Gracias por su sintonía
[Música]